- - Hélènene Buzzetti Michel C r
PaPaul Journet bonsoir. Ça a fat
bebeaucoup de chemin cette
hihistoire de taxe mais on ne st
auaucun détail   cette activité
nonon-vaccinés au Québec   CNN t
lele monde en ont parlé   chacun
chcherche beaucoup de pays chere
unune manièrere originale et ese
quque cela en est une?
JeJe vais vous entendre là-d-des
- - cela quoi j'arrive c'est qun
paparle beaucoup de la vaccinatn
obobligatoire, on dit qu'on doit
ininstaurer une vaccination
obobligatoire mais voilà u un
dédévissage de la vaccination
obobligatoire voilà c cela quoia
pepeut ressembler   entendons ns
mmêmeme si la loi québécoise sua
sasanté publique le permis
ththéoririque d'envoyer quelqu'n
dadans une piècece pour les forà
lului insérer une aiguille de
foforce dans le bras, mêmeme si
c'c'est possiblement permis, das
leles faits personne ne songe à
cecela.
ququand on part de la vaccinatin
obobligatoire ordi vacciné ou
sisinon il y aura une conséquene
donc c'est une conséquence
pépécuniaire   les gens prochese
leleur porte monnaient ça peut
efeffectivement avoir un effet t
c'c'est effectivement ce que
MoMonsieur Dubé nous dit quand l
didit qu'il y a une augmentation
plplus grande des prises de
rerendez-vous pour une premièree
dodose
- - j'avais beau reposer la
ququestion et je vais continuer
momon tour de table, mais pourqi
nene pas alors dire que la
vavaccination est obligatoire?
DeDessureault ne rentrera pas ue
aiaiguille de forces meilleuresà
dedes amendes et ça sera le même
rérésultat
l'l'impression générale 24 heurs
apaprès?s?
- - Légèrerement pire que cellee
j'j'ai eu hier c'est pas quelque
chchose qui va marcher très s b
çaça va êtrtre compliqué et je e
susuis pas sûr r que ça ici beap
dede gens à s se faire vaccinera
fifin   je ne pense pas que la
vavaccination obligatoire soit e
memeilleure solution non plus ms
onon a vu la réaction des trois
prpremiers ministres conservates
: : Alberta Saskatchewan et
OnOntario il se dit qu'il ne
totoucherait pas sa.
- - 24 ans plus tard et une
sesemaine et demi plus tard pare
quque Monsieur Legault avait
tétélégraphié ses intentions à a
fifin décembre mais on a laissé
cecela flotter dans leur et on t
rerevenu à l la charge   j'image
quque le gouvernement est contet
ququ'on parle de cela plutôt t e
dudu départ de Dr Arruda, depuis
unune ou deux semaines ce qu'on
enentend sur tout cela colèrere
cocontre les non-vaccinés, maisu
fufur et à m mesure qu'on réflét
plplus concrètete en a une
cocontribution santé on réalise
quque c'est plus compliqué en
prpratique et aussi que ça pose
plplusieurs problèmemes de prine
la prétention de base du
gogouvernement c'est de dire que
çaça va augmenter le taux de
vavaccination et ça pourrait sas
dodoute convaincre certaines
pepersonnes. mêmeme si ça a une
ututilité pour certaines persons
onon réalise que ça pourrait avr
unun effet de ressac auprès s de
d'd'autres personnes
rérécalcitrantes qui pourraiente
brbraquer et mêmeme se radicalir
etet enfin il y a des gens
vuvulnérables à q qui on demandt
unune contribution et on se
dedemande comment ça
fofonctionnerait, allez-vous vor
unun sans-abri lui demandent
ététiquette parce que il n'est s
vavacciné?
C'C'est vraiment plusieurs
prproblèmemes actuels il faudrat
réréfléchir avant d'aller de
l'l'avant.
- - alors comment protéger les
plplus vulnérables et comment
fafaire le tri. je vais me faire
écécouter Monsieur Trudeau, très
prprudent mais en mêmeme temps e
vavaut pas ) parce que ça va das
lele mêmeme sens de son discoure
totout faire de faire vacciner s
gegens.
- - Nous avions pris des mesures
trtrès s fortes pour encourager
leles gens de se faire vacciner.
LeLes provinces ont pris
dedes mesures très s fortes déj,
alalors il n'y a pas
unune opposition de la part du
gogouvernement à c ce qu'on pree
dedes mesures fortes.
MaMais nous allons toujours
chchercher à c ce que ces mesurs
sosoient efficaces, soient
dadans le respect des principes
etet des valeurs et puissent
nonous faire avancer.
C'C'est pour ça que les détails
sosont aussi importants.
- - Hélènene, il ne se mouille ?
TrTrop en entendant les détails?
- - Il n'a pas vraiment le choix
paparce que c'est lui en
acaccompagné la chorale qui a
bebeaucoup collaboré à l la came
dede vaccination en croissance n
adadversaire M. O'Toole il ne re
jajamais une occasion de
l'l'attaquer sur cela!
IlIl a imposé ce climat dans
lelequel on attaque les non-
vavaccinés. lui en tant
ququ'employeur fédéral il a
ininstauré la vaccination
obobligatoire des fonctionnaires
féfédéraux et qu'on y pense héls
vavacciner quel est la
coconséquence?
VoVous êtetes suspendu sans sole
auaucun salaire de 60 000 $ que
vovous ne touchez plus et mêmeme
plplus quelle amende auxquels
sosonge Monsieur Legault   il
seserait bien mal vu d'êtrtre
cocontent alors qu'il fait la me
chchose
- - moi je vois une grande
didifférence avec le passeport
vavaccinal je trouve que
l'l'élargissement se défend
bebeaucoup mieux parce qu'on
cocomprend la logique de santé
pupublique derrièrere cela   sis
gegens qui ne sont pas vaccinés
n'n'ont pas accès s à c certains
lilieux, on réduit la possibilié
dede contactct et donc de
cocontamination et des pressions
susur les systèèmemes hospitali
ilil y a donc une logique claire
etet préventive de santé publiqe
alalors que une contribution
sasanté, on arrive après s le c,
onon présume que les gens vont
rérépondre à d des pénalités et
apaprès s le pire de la cinquièe
vavague, donc il y a toutes sors
dede problèmemes pratiques se pà
cecela et on a mêmeme pas parléu
dadanger d'induire dans les
sysystèmemes de santé une logiqe
cocontributeurs payèrerent c'est
popour ça que le passeport
vavaccinal me semble beaucoup ps
unun bon travail et dans certais
cocommerçants sont beaucoup plus
cocohérents que les mesures de
sasanté publique plutôt t que ds
fafaire payer les non-vaccinés r
susurtout la majorité est en
cocolèrere... vous voulez de la
jujustice et en voilà!!
- - Je dirais juste là-d-dessuse
popour les fonctionnaires fédérx
ilils sont presque tous en
tétélétravail donc la logique de
PaPaul est peut-êtrtre vraie mas
pependant fonction publique
féfédérale.
- - on les voit avec Macron
l'l'attrait de faire du ménage
popolitique en disant convalesct
memerdier, il y a un peu de cel?
- - Il y a beaucoup de sang la
raraison pourquoi Monsieur Legat
fafait cela si punitif c'est pas
popour que plus de gens se fasst
vavacciner les vraiment dans une
lologique de mission   pourquoi
MoMonsieur Trudeau est aussi
prprudent?
C'C'est que ça sonne poigner c't
lala loi de la santé qui lui doe
unune seule âmeme c'est de
trtranscrire les 30 zéro provine
dodouche imaginez-vous le
gogouvernement fédéral de réduie
leles 30 zéro province.
mmêmeme si ça cause un problèmee
d'd'universalité et ce que
MoMonsieur Legault propose, le
gogouvernement fédéral ne va pas
rérépondre avec la seule arme
ququ'il a qui elle a loi de la
cacanadienne de la santé   a
- - alors on va les écouter.
- - Il y a des gens en santé
pupublique qui souhaite que les
gegens se passent vaccinés et qi
onont des gros doutes, un
didirecteur de la santé publique
enen Gaspésie, qui décide dede e
atattention et qu'on fait fausse
roroute on l'écoute.
DrDr YV BONNIER-VIGER, santé
pupubl., Gaspésie-Îles-de-la-Ma.
- - Quand on regarde
lala proposition qui nous a été
fafaite, elle va à l l'encontre
dede plusieurs de ces valeurs et
dede ces principes scientifiques
dede base dans le domaine
dede la santé publique. Alors,
cece n'est pas une solution
ququ'on peut lancer comme ça
dudu jour au lendemain.
JeJe pense que ça exige,
sisi on veut la considérer,
bebeaucoup d'examen et de débat.
- - Est-ce qu'il y a eu beaucoup
d'd'examens de débat?
- - Non parce que ça a commencé
avavec une commande politique
prpremier ministre Legault, et
l'l'examen est plutôt t unique s
ilil se fait au ministèrere des
FiFinances. on est en train de
réréfléchir entre économistes et
fifinalistes de la meilleure fan
dede quelle institution va
prprélever la contribution et
ququelle sera sa hauteur et à ql
momoment va le faire, est-ce qul
y y aura des exemptions?
OnOn est tout de suite tombé das
lele coma avant de penser à l la
réréflexion sur les moyens, et
popour faire un lien avec les gs
dede la santé publique il faut
auaussi penser à l l'approche da
sasanté publique puisque la grae
mamajorité qui travail ce sont s
inintervenants sociaux de la saé
dadans toutes les conditions de
vivie, pauvreté condition menta,
ininégalités de revenus,s, qui
pepeuvent mener à d des problème
sasanté donc ce n'est pas
susurprenant que les gens de la
sasanté publique soient méfiants
d'd'une telle mesure punitive et
dedes effets régressifs.
- - faut aussi comprendre la
sosociologie des gens qui ne sot
papas vaccinés ce ne sont pas ds
gegens qui vont tous manifestert
ququi ont de l'argent.
HéHélènene je vous demandais ese
quque ça n'aurait pas été plus
sisimple pour le Québec plus
frfrontal de dire qu'on va
s's'assumer et que de plutôt t e
dede les faire Farnoborough avec
l'l'alcool et machin juste
obobligeait la vaccination et cx
ququi ne le feront pas auront ds
amamendes.
- - c'est un peu cela qu'on fai.
- - oui mais non. on ne les fait
papas on dit que si ce n'est pas
obobligatoire et on ajoute plein
dede mes.
- - on ne peut pas se prononcer
paparce qu'on n'a pas le détail
coconcret de la mesure qui est
enenvisagée mais ce comédie
séséculièrere 2, Avenue préconie
c'c'est celle de la fiscalité dc
onon ferait cela par le rapport
dedes New-Yorkais une ligne de
plplus
l'l'autre avenue ça serait de
prprendre nos registres du régie
d'd'assurance-maladie et devoir
ququi n'a pas été vacciné et
d'd'envoyer une amende par la
poposte. le résultat est le mêm:
fafaites-vous vacciner où il y
auaura un résultat. beaucoup par
dedes personnes moins privilégis
etet des sans-abri des sans-
papapiers, ce cas-là Q Québeccie
cocomédie c'est que ce sont deux
cacatégories de gens qui ne
reremplissent pas de rapport
d'd'impôt t et qui n'ont pas
d'd'adresse ou pas d'adresse
coconnue de l'État et donc les
avavenues qu'on privilégia Québc
nene sont pas de nature à
pépénaliser ces deux catégoriese
pepersonnes.
- - je repose ma question mais a
nene serait pas plus clair de de
quque la vaccination est
obobligatoire Québec, comme en
ItItalie, et ceux qui n'y vont s
s's'exposeront à d des amendes.
- - oui mais est-ce que ça va
mamarcher?
OnOn peut bien décréter la
vavaccination universelle mais e
nene suis pas sûr r que 100 % ds
gegens de 50 ans et plus sous
pepeine d'une visite de la polie
sosont vaccinés en Italie. est-e
quque ça va donner quelque chos?
DaDans les ports d'impôt t 40 %s
QuQuébécois ne paye pas d'impôts
esest-ce que ça va êtrtre utile?
- - On les fait pas, et puis en
acachetant la SAQ.
- - je pense que ça donne rien.e
fafaçon incantatoire décret prie
lala vaccination universelle.
- - je pense que ça risquerait
ququand mêmeme de donner quelque
chchose on se demande si le gain
seserait suffisant pour donner
totous les troubles qu'on se
dodonne. pour revenir à c ce que
vovous dîtetes sur lele plan des
coconséquences entre la
vavaccination obligatoire et la
tataxe de contribution c'est vri
quque ça se ressemble mais le
memessage est la logique est qud
mmêmeme très s différent. on dit
ququ'au lieu de faire appel aux
gegens en tant que client et
coconsommateurs, là o on fait
dadavantage avec la vaccination
obobligatoire on fait davantage
apappel à u un devoir citoyen de
prprotéger les autres et début
tétélé prirent pour notre systèe
dede santé qui approchent à u ue
phphase cinq. il y a quand mêmee
unune supèrere enfant les messas
etet c'est ce qui a été fait ily
a a déjà e eu de la vaccination
obobligatoire et Québec élit en
exexistant les enfants dans les
didifférents provinces.
- - Dr Arruda, on part de la tae
dedes non-vaccinés plutôt t quee
DrDr Arruda, 24 heures plus tar,
etet puis?
VoVous avez écrit là-d-dessus, s
enen êtetes dans votre analyse.
- - il est parti et il ne
rereviendra pas   je note que
pependant que tout le monde estn
trtrain de se demander qui serae
nonouveau directeur national
pepermanent jeje pense que celui
esest en poste bail parenté rime
mamais va rester pendant toute a
crcrise de la cinquièmeme vaguet
popossiblement jusqu'à l la finu
mamandat du gouvernement actuel.
totoutes les idées de réforme pr
lele directeur de la santé
pupublique ne soient plus un
adadjoint il va falloir sans
chchanger la loi donc il va
fafalloir s'en remettre à
l'l'attitude du nouveau directer
etet espérer que de sa propre
ininitiative soit plus transpart
mamais on n'est pas allé cherchr
unun médecin de terrain pour alr
brbrasser la cage mais il est
plplutôt t un médecin de carrièe
ququi est déjà  à l la taille de
l'l'INESSS. donc ce qui s'attenà
unun changement radical je ne
pepense pas
- - est-ce que Arruda était le
fufusible qu'on avait sauté pour
rerendre les semaines plus
apapaisées?
- - Ça fait parti de la réflexin
dudu gouvernement sont en mêmeme
tetemps s il utilise comme
paparatonnerre   beaucoup à m me
susur le dos du Dr Arruda il n't
plplus là
- - vous trouvez qu'on a été dur
avavec lui?
- - De façon générale oui. il
didisait la mêmeme chose que ler
FaFauci aux États-Unis et on
reregarde la pandémie aujourd'hi
etet tout le monde s'est trompé
totout endroit qui n'était pas
pipire que les autres mais là il
n'n'est plus là, , le paratonnee
n'n'est plus la et son succèss
dodonnerait un homme très s pru.
- - on l'a vu là c c'est la prue
inincarnée.
- - quelque chose qu'on reprocht
c'c'était un manque de clarté, s
exexplications répétées plus
clclaires
- - je suis assez d'accord avec
MiMichel on a été trop dur avece
DrDr Arruda effectivement le
gogouvernement paratonnerre avec
soson départ et je ne suis pas r
quque le gouvernement était si
cocontent que cela de les perdr
- - ils auraient pu la garder?
- - À partir du moment où on
cocommença se questionner sur sn
sosort, M. Arruda trouvait
didifficile et critique de ses
cocollègugues, c'est pour ça que
n'n'adhèrere pas à l la thèsesea
tataxe comme diversion je pense
quque c'est surtout sur les
dédélestages dont on n'a à p peu
prprès s pas parlé avec le premr
miministre était pourtant une
grgrande crise
- - on va en reparler demain et
dedemain avons parlé des écoles
onon est à p peu près s tous
coconvaincus qu'elles vont rouvr
mamais si jamais elle ne devrait
papas ouvrir ce n'est pas